[موسيقى]
هو الاسلام السياسي كان يزعم انه يريد ان
يؤوب بالحياه العامه الى الدين يريد ان
يؤب بالاقتصاد وبالسياسه وبالجيش والجهاد
وبالتعليم وبالاعلام وحتى بالعلوم البحته
وبمناهج التعليم هذه كانت مزاعم الاسلام
السياسي بانه اريد ان يحكم الناس ليطبق
هذا الاسلام الشمولي ولكن ثبت ان النظريه
خضراء الرماديه والتجربه خضراء انها اذا
اردت ان تحول الاقتصاد
المعاصر الكثيف المعقد العالمي الموصول
بكل الدنيا اذا اردت ان تحوله الى
الاقتصاد الاسلامي فهذا زعم كبير
ويحتاج الى دوره حضاريه الذي حدث في الغرب
منذ القرن السادس عشر ان هنالك نهضه
حضاريه كامله كما حدث في القرون الاسلاميه
الاولى لكن مثل بسيط جدا في السودان مثلا
اكثر ما كانوا يحتمون به هو التربيه
واعاده صياغه الانسان السوداني ولكن مناهج
التعليم بالكامل لمده 30 عاما
[موسيقى]
اغلبهم كانوا معلمين وانتشروا ولكن في
السودان القرار نفسه القرار السياسي
المتحكم في المناهج كان في يد الحركه
الاسلاميه
ولكنها لم تولي التعليم هذا الاهتمام الذي
يستحقه رغم انها تحدثت عن ثوره التعليم
والمفارقه هو ان الجيل الذي خرج بالملايين
واسقط الانداس هو خريج هذا المنهج فانا
اسميته منهج الشيعي والتقديس كان يهتم بان
يقدس المعلومات في ذهن الطالب بتحفيظه
[موسيقى]
مقدار هائل من الاحاديث والايات ولكن هذا
هذه الشيئيه والتجديد ذابت عند اول اختبار
عند اول مواجهه
[موسيقى]